En este video vamos a aprender sobre el
movimiento circular uniformemente variado o MCV;
también se le conoce como movimiento circular
uniformemente acelerado o MCUA. Como recordatorio,
en otros videos hemos visto que podemos expresar
la velocidad como el cambio de la posición con
respecto del tiempo y la aceleración como
el cambio de la velocidad con respecto del
tiempo. Esto aplica en términos generales
para el movimiento rectilíneo así como el
angular. Un movimiento circular uniforme, MCU,
es aquel que describe una trayectoria circular,
una circunferencia, con rapidez constante y
velocidad variable. Recuerda que la rapidez es
una cantidad escalar y la velocidad es un vector,
de modo que no cambia su magnitud, pero sí su
dirección; esto quiere decir que siempre tarda
el mismo tiempo en dar cada vuelta, es decir,
tiene un movimiento periódico. Algunos ejemplos
de MCU son las ruedas de un carro que se mueve con
rapidez constante, las aspas de un ventilador
en marcha, un satélite en órbita alrededor de
la Tierra. Para describir el movimiento en un MCU
solemos medir el ángulo que recorre y lo llamamos
desplazamiento angular, se mide en radianes y se
representa con la letra fi (φ). Recuerda que un
ángulo de 360° = 2π radianes. De manera análoga
al movimiento rectilíneo, la razón de cambio
del desplazamiento angular en el tiempo se llama
velocidad angular, se mide en radianes por segundo
y se representa con la letra omega (ω). La rapidez
angular es la magnitud de omega, la aceleración
angular es la razón de cambio de la velocidad
angular en el tiempo, se mide en radianes por
segundo al cuadrado y se representa con la letra
alfa (α). Una consecuencia de que en un MCU la
rapidez sea constante es que describe ángulos
iguales en tiempos iguales y, por lo tanto,
no tiene aceleración tangencial angular, pero sí
en dirección del centro de movimiento normal. Esta
aceleración se debe al cambio de la dirección de
la velocidad y se le llama aceleración centrípeta.
Cuando un cuerpo se mueve y describe una
trayectoria circular, una circunferencia,
y tiene una aceleración angular constante, tiene
un movimiento circular uniformemente variado. Hay
varios ejemplos sencillos de la vida cotidiana:
el movimiento de las aspas de un ventilador al
encenderlo o apagarlo, la rueda de una bicicleta
cuando empieza a andar o se está deteniendo,
una pelota atada a una cuerda que hacemos
girar, una pokebola. La diferencia fundamental
entre un MCU y un MCV es que en el primero la
velocidad angular es constante y en el segundo
no. No tener velocidad constante implica que
hay una aceleración. Para el caso del MCV,
la aceleración es constante; podemos pensar que de
ahí proviene el nombre de uniformemente variado,
de que la velocidad varía. Como en el caso del
MCU, el MCV también tiene aceleración centrípeta,
pero aquí pasan más cosas debido al cambio de la
velocidad: al cambiar la magnitud de la velocidad
hay una aceleración tangencial y al variar la
velocidad angular se genera una aceleración
angular. Vamos a analizar con más detalle el
movimiento del cuerpo que va girando en un
instante dado. Recuerda que la aceleración angular
es constante, de modo que alfa es igual a una
constante. Supón que el movimiento que estudiamos
inicia en el punto P₀, el cual forma un ángulo
φ₀ con respecto a la horizontal, un instante de
tiempo después está en el punto P, el cual forma
un ángulo φ con respecto a la horizontal, como la
aceleración angular es constante esto tiene que
ser igual al cambio de la velocidad angular entre
el cambio en el tiempo. El cambio en la velocidad
es la velocidad final menos la velocidad inicial;
el cambio en el tiempo es el tiempo final menos el
tiempo inicial. Podemos escoger que nuestro tiempo
inicial de t₀ sea 0, y esta fórmula se reduce a:
como escogemos que el tiempo inicial sea 0 esto
queda como la diferencia de la velocidad angular
ω - ω₀ / t, multiplicamos ambos lados de la
ecuación por t, y nos queda que αt = ω - ω₀,
y podemos despejar ω, esto es: la velocidad
angular es igual a una velocidad angular inicial
más algo que le vamos sumando o restando, y es un
factor que depende de la aceleración. Observa que
la ecuación de ω tiene la forma y = mx + b, la de
una recta, y esto implica que el valor promedio
de la velocidad angular se alcanza a la mitad del
camino del intervalo entre el tiempo inicial y el
tiempo final. De manera más formal, hay un teorema
que dice que un cuerpo en movimiento uniformemente
acelerado recorre, en un determinado intervalo
de tiempo, el mismo espacio que sería recorrido
por un cuerpo que se desplace con velocidad
constante e igual a la velocidad media del
primero. Consideremos que la velocidad aumenta
de manera uniforme en dos instantes de tiempo,
esto es lo mismo que considerar una velocidad
media constante entre esos dos instantes. Esto
es porque el área por debajo de la velocidad que
representa la distancia recorrida es la misma
en los dos casos. Ahora, la velocidad angular
es igual al cambio del desplazamiento angular
entre el cambio en el tiempo; ω es igual
al cambio de φ entre el cambio en t, o bien
φ - φ₀ / t - t₀. Volvemos a escoger el tiempo
inicial como 0 y tenemos que ω = φ - φ₀ / t,
de modo que al despejar φ tenemos que ωt = φ - φ₀;
y con la relación de la velocidad media de arriba,
podemos escribir que omega promedio u omega
barra (ϖ) por t es igual a φ - φ₀, y usando
el valor de ϖ que encontramos anteriormente, ½ω
+ ω₀t = φ - φ₀; sustituyendo el valor de ω que
encontramos anteriormente, ω = ω₀ + αt, esto se
puede reescribir como ½(ω₀ + αt + ω₀), todo por t
es igual a φ - φ₀. Podemos agrupar dos veces ω₀,
y al expandir el paréntesis de la multiplicación
nos queda: ω₀t + ½αt² = φ - φ₀, que a su vez
podemos reescribir como φ = φ₀ + ω₀t + ½αt²; y
si comparamos este resultado con lo que conocemos
para el movimiento rectilíneo uniformemente
variado, vemos que se parecen mucho. Las
ecuaciones de posición en velocidad y aceleración
se ven iguales a las de posición angular,
velocidad angular y aceleración angular, pero
en vez de x tenemos φ, en vez de v, ω, y en vez
de a, α. Ahora, dijimos que en el MCV el cambio de
la magnitud de la velocidad provoca que haya una
aceleración tangencial, y al variar la velocidad
angular se genera una aceleración angular,
además de que hay una aceleración centrípeta
como en el MCU. En realidad si hacemos un diagrama
de fuerzas, podemos ver que la aceleración angular
es el resultado de las otras dos aceleraciones,
de modo que la dirección del vector de aceleración
está dada por la suma vectorial de la aceleración
centrípeta y de la aceleración tangencial,
mientras que su magnitud será la suma de las
componentes que se obtiene usando el Teorema
de Pitágoras. Así que en este video vimos que
las ecuaciones del movimiento uniformemente
acelerado se ven igual para los casos rectilíneo y
circular, lo único que cambia es que, en un caso,
a las variables las llamamos posición, velocidad y
aceleración, y, en el otro, son posición angular,
velocidad angular y aceleración angular. Con esto
terminamos este video, nos vemos en el siguiente.